united nations secretary general antonio
guterres has called for all troops to be
withdrawn from around ukraine's subordia
nuclear power station the plant has come
under repeated shelling guterres was
speaking during talks with ukraine's
president volody zielinski and the
turkish leader rejected erdogan in the
city of levive in western ukraine the
leaders also discussed exchanging
prisoners of war and increasing
ukrainian grain exports millions of tons
of wheat and maize are still stuck in
black sea ports
guterres repeated calls for a safe zone
around zappo regia
military equipment and personnel should
be withdrawn from the plant
further deployment of forces or
equipment to the site must be avoided
the area needs to be demilitarized
and we must tell it
as it is
any potential damage to zaporizia is
suicide
and ukraine says it has obtained new
troubling intelligence about a russian
plot involving the nuclear power plant
dw's correspondent matthias boulinga and
leve has more
yeah
russia seems to have
announced a free day tomorrow asking
only the crews that will be on duty that
will really run the operations at the
power plant to
come to work and all the other stuff not
and that is of course something
that worries ukraine of course these
informations have not been confirmed by
the russian side it's exclusively
ukrainian uh intelligence information uh
there has been an announcement by russia
however that they
are accusing ukraine of planning to do
something a provocation
as they call it there tomorrow so it
seems that tomorrow is going to be a
critical day in this power plant that
has been
under pressure for quite some time being
shelled from different sides
we don't know exactly from where and we
also heard that the situation inside the
plant is quite dire with high pressure
on the staff there and a lot of military
equipment stored near or even inside the
facility we don't know this exactly
but
the situation is tense yes
both erdogan and guterres have stressed
that there is positive momentum for
diplomatic efforts after that grain deal
was achieved a couple of weeks back is
that optimism shared by president
zielinski
it depends on what we are talking about
there are quite a few things that
diplomats can do at this stage one thing
is to try to resolve uh the situation
around the power plant um another thing
is exchanges of prisoners and also they
all of them have said today that they
want to speed up the grain exports uh to
get more ships in and out of ukrainian
ports that of course requires work with
all sides so there is of course a role
for diplomacy to play at this stage but
the question is
is this going towards a diplomatic
solution of the conflict as erdogan has
suggested and that's clearly not what is
happening at the moment matthias
with the latest from leve in western
ukraine thanks
now the turkish president seems
confident that he can change the course
of the war i asked our correspondent
dorian jones in istanbul how erdog might
try to get the two sides to the
negotiating table
well i think he sees his current grain
deal which turkey helped to broker along
with the united nations between ukraine
and russia as the
vehicle that could ultimately take these
two swaring parties to a negotiation
table now basically turkey is very
emboyed by the fact that already 25
ships have uh passed uh thanks to this
ukraine deal to the world market
carrying around half a million tons of
grain now that is seen by turkey is
evidence that these two warring parties
can at least work together on this deal
now erdogan sees the first step will be
to build on the success of this deal
solely building some kind of trust
between the two sides which would be
ultimately key in any negotiation now
erdogan i think is focusing at least on
resolving the current crisis over this
nuclear power station possibly if some
deal can be brokered there this will be
further momentum that ultimately could
bring the side to negotiating table
along with talks of prisoner swaps which
erdogan is also believed to have
discussed during his meeting with the
russian president vladimir putin who is
met twice in the last month and this is
another reason why erdogan does feel in
some ways confident that turkey in many
ways is the best place partner to
facilitate a deal when the two sides are
ready to talk
what does erdogan himself hope to gain
from positioning himself at the center
of these diplomatic efforts
well turkey really is a neighbor with
ukraine and russia and has close ties
with both sides has been really
effective very badly by this conflict
certainly on an economic level it's been
hit by soaring food prices along with
the rest of the world so third one is
very keen to somehow bring an end to
this conflict and bring some stability
to the region but beyond that i think
erdogan sees an opportunity again to
play the world leading figure he sees
himself as really the only man that can
ultimately bring the sides together
given the fact he does have close ties
with the ukrainian and the russian
presidents and he sees this as an
opportunity again of putting himself on
the world stage which he knows he
believes will play well with supporters
in turkey and also the fact that he is
facing re-election next year and also he
will see as a chance that if he's
successful and bring some kind of peace
this will also silence he believes
criticism of turkey's close ties to
putin which turkey has faced growing
criticism from its western allies
especially as turkey is not enforcing
western sanctions against russia
many factors at play there dorian jones
in istanbul thank you
and i'm now pleased to welcome alexander
sherba he's a former ambassador to
austria from ukraine he's also the
author of ukraine versus darkness a
collection of essays based on the two
and a half decades he spend as a career
diplomat and speech writer for ukrainian
leaders mr sheriva so good to see you um
i want to begin by asking you rejected
erdogan says he thinks a lasting peace
can evolve from the grain deal do you
share that optimism
well it can be the beginning
of the past to the lasting peace but
the real chance for the lasting peace
would be the moment when we start
pushing putting back
uh from our territory that would be the
moment uh when uh putin
feels uh he is losing losing this war
and that would be the moment when he
decides to really give diplomacy a
chance because until now whatever came
whatever conversations about diplomacy
and peaceful solution that came from
moscow from the this genocidal uh maniac
in the kremlin
it was all just
a show
he didn't mean
anything by it
um
so
when erdogan now comes face to face for
the first time with the ukrainian
president saying that he
supports ukraine in the fight does that
mean that they are a trustworthy ally to
bring that message to to putin you
think well
it just so happened that erdogan is
right now the main negotiator between
ukraine and russia
uh
if there is any chance of you know
bringing any kind of helpful signals
from one side to another it's uh via
ankara it's wire turkey and we are
thankful for that we also thankful we
are thankful for the uh weapons that uh
uh turkey supplies uh to us to uh fight
russia but again uh as a former diplomat
i i have to say right now i don't see
much chance for diploma any kind of
diplomatic solution just yesterday uh
russia
destroyed
with an ex
extremely expensive missile rocket
iskandar a dormitory
in kharkiv where people with hearing
impairment lived so 17 people died many
are wounded it just it's genocide people
were hit without even hearing that
something was coming their way and this
is what's happening every day he just
mind and bobby trapped europe's biggest
uh
atomic
nuclear uh power plant so this is what
we're dealing here with it just it's
it's it's a man
it's a maniac uh
who feels like the world isn't ready to
give him
any you know red lines and
does it make any sense to even to even
attempt diplomacy with what you call a
maniac
at some point when the maniac realizes
that
he is losing and losing maybe everything
then it would be a chance that the
remains of his common sense would uh
play a role but right now
he is just this blood thirsty creature
killing thousands in ukraine deporting
thousands making millions uh homeless
and
there is no end in sight uh with what he
is doing right now as we are speaking
the right the reason once again the air
raid siren in ukraine this is our
reality every day this is like 81 years
ago when uh the nazis attacked soviet
union he's doing all the same things
mass killings uh deportations um so it's
just it's just it's it's the history
once again relieving the history
now erdogan was certainly hoping to not
leave
lev today empty-handed but he sort of
did right because he was certainly
rebuffed by by zielinski uh saying that
you know if you if you want to talk you
first need to leave ukrainian territory
were you at all bothered by the fact
that you know erdogan came to ukraine to
tell the president that it needs to
negotiate with russia
because the president certainly wasn't
buying it either
well this is what erdogan has been doing
all along and
we aren't disappointed we aren't
encouraged it just erdogan doing his
thing
um
maybe maybe uh there is some sense to it
but at this point right now i i don't
see much a chance
of this talk of diplomatic solution of a
compromise with a bloodthirsty maniac
who conduct genocide right now as we
speak
so
it's just i'm not very optimistic i
wasn't very optimistic before this
meeting i'm not very optimistic after it
but i'm very optimistic that now as we
speak uh there are three big uh
ammunition depots in russia and in
occupied crimea that are burning ukraine
is doing her thing we are destroying uh
the armed forces of the russian
federation and i want to switch topics a
bit there is a controversial debate
going on in many eu countries and i
would love to hear your opinion on it
should there be a visa ban for russian
citizens
yes as a ukrainian i say yes
because
my family lives in vienna so many
ukrainian refugees live in vienna and
they they they're just struggling every
day despite all the help that they're
getting from the west and they're seeing
these big numerous groups of russian
tourists just strolling through downtown
enjoying their life like nothing
happened
what about dissidents though people
trying to leave russia because they face
oppression in in their own country
i hope i hope uh
we can draw a line between dissidents
and tourists because indeed uh we must
do it in a way that uh dissidents don't
suffer that people who are dying and
seeking medical help don't suffer but
just doing the tourist thing as if
nothing was happening it was happening
is is wrong
you talked about separation before um
alleging that putin was or his troops
were were um booby-trapping the nuclear
plant and the ukrainian intelligence
services have been warning of russian
activity there what do you believe they
are plotting guterres uh the u.n
secretary general said any damage to the
plan would equal to suicide
i think russians
are doing what putin likes the
the best they are raising the stakes of
the game
they uh
like they enjoy every minute of uh this
fear that the world is feeling that
europe is feeling uh it comes from you
know the soviet union soviet time when
the world was feared fearful of soviet
union now
uh they hear us again uh so they respect
us this is the russians thinking right
now so they are raising the stakes but i
do hope that they have this modicum of
you know common sense not to do this
crazy insane thing from which russia can
suffer immensely too
and you're not alone in that alexander
sherba thank you for your time
thank you
you